[Musique]
j'aurais vénus khoury ghata je suis
libano française je viens en france
depuis bientôt quarante huit ans pendant
des années la langue arabe jouer des
tours à la langue française
j'étais perdue entre les deux longs que
j'avais tout le temps l'impression en
écrivant de traverser des frontières
entre deux pays et de payer une taxe
chaque fois que je traversais ses
frontières jusqu'au jour où j'ai étudié
la langue arabe en moi et je me suis
contenté de la langue française à
laquelle j'ai insuffler les saveurs les
odeurs de la langue arabe la poésie en
france était réservé aux hommes il y
avait quelques femmes qui émergeait
depuis quelques années nous sommes en
train de travailler
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on étende le
cette connaissance de la position des
poètes modernes et que les poètes
modernes aille dans les écoles et
fassent connaître dans aux élèves lors
que hésite je suis pas une militante
féministe mais je me rends compte que
les personnages de mes romans les femmes
de mes romans sont nous vouloir sans le
savoir
j'ai fait du militantisme j'ai raconté
des femmes qui sont soumises à des uns
des lois archaïques qui se révoltent ou
qu'ils se rendent pas compte dans les
sept pierres pour la femme adultère donc
je devais être révolté en moi même
contre cette soumission des femmes pour
avoir écrit tous ses livres dont tous
ses livres il ya une femme qui est
malmené par les autres j'ai commencé par
qu'il ya des romans très des textes très
littéraire et on m'a fait comprendre
très vite chez les éditeurs qui m'ont
publié qui vaut mieux raconter des
histoires des romans avec des
personnages avec un grand public pour ne
pas dire gros public et pourquoi on
laisse aux hommes le droit d'écrire des
textes épurés qui font avancer la
littérature mais pas des femmes des
femmes doivent être des conteuses
raconteuse d'histoires ils doivent
tricoter une histoire facile pour une
femme qui aime les romans
qui font pleurer margot dans la chambre
de la pourquoi
[Musique]